We're gonna start with somebody
He's a boyfriend
He's a bestfriend
He was the beast
Khylin Rhambo
He's the Beta
Who now has a werewolf girlfriend
Dylan Sprayberry
Now this next guy you might know him
Is like the protector of Beacon Hills
But what you might not know about him
Is that he's
actually a huge fan of flash dance
It's Tyler Posey
He's such a big fan he did it twice
Now he's the man behind it all executive producer Jeff Davis
Okay no matter how loud you guys scream
I think this next person could probably top it. It's Holland Roden
I love you
And because we love like a
potential redemption story on Teen Wolf
Or actually bringing out someone you might have considert of villain in the past
But who knows what's in his future. It's Cody Christian
The stage is now a hassert thanks to Tyler's lover flash dance
It was worth it
Okay well to kick things off i'm gonna
throw it to Jeff
I think he has a little something he wants to say to you guys
Yes. Well there are a lot of you here
Yes
Every year we comes to Comic Con
And we been nounst the next season of Teen Wolf
And every year we've been able to celebrate with the fans
And this season
This year is a little different but no last reason to celebrate
We're gonna hit a hundred episodes at the end of season 6
And we also...
yeah that's amazing
And we decided that a hundred episodes is also a good place to stop
Yes
This will be the finale
These next 20 episodes will be the finale season of Teen Wolf
Yes
I know
We're sad about it and it's bittersweet
But we're so happy to be able to come to Comic Con and share with you guys
I'm gonna start to cry i think
I know
Tyler has to say something about it
Go for it
Omg you guys so yeah this is it
This is the routine that we build
Everybody that we put in the seats. It's coming to an end
And I just want to let everybody know from Jeff and everybody here's heart
That this is been the biggest movement that we ever been a part of
This isn't just a show. This is a family
You guys are all a part of it
You guys have helped us get to this point
And...
I hope you guys know that we love you guys
I do crazy sh*t like this because i wanna make you guys smile and laugh
You mean so much to me and so this ending is the end of a huge era for all of us
And me specifically cause this is you know i care so  deeply about the show
And i wanna be the leader of the show
So i'm have to find something else to be a leader of when this is over
But this is huge. I love
each and every single one of you
And i wanna come and hug every single one of you when this is over
But I...
We also. We should probably say a word. Tyler has been talking to Dylan i've texting with Dylan
And told him the news. And Dylan send the most beautiful message about how bittersweet it was
And how, what an amazing thing we're been able to do
We miss him here
We wish he could come but he's still at home recuperating
And i've gotta ask since Holland was here
from the beginning too. Holland say something about this. The show
Ohh gosh
I mean...
I grew up with this like just gang of boys
Basically my entire twenties and...
I was a boy back then too
You're still a boy Jeff
Look at the people. L, Look at all the people here man.
Look at what we created.
Everybody turn around. T, take a look at the sea of people.
How many people are in here right now?
I'm so proud of us.
I'm so happy.
I love..
This is the greatest
-We're gonna need a spin-off.
I think JR and Ian should do a spin-off together.
Uhh, we've already got one.
Just not being filmed.
Uh, I think one of the great things about Peter is how consistent he is,
and how fundamentally he doesn't change.
Uhm, regardless of whether he's doing something that looks good,
or looks bad.
Uh he's exactly the same guy underneath.
I should start... I think so,
Ok let's see, let's see, let's see.
-It's gotta be a Blink 182 song.
I could be your hero baby.
or a...
*Starts singing Hungry Like the Wolf*
-Did you forget the question?
*Still continues to sing*
But that that one.. not that song.
I guess you have to sing your answer Tyler.
-And Dylan.
Is it my turn?
What's that umm...
What's that umm, Katy Perry song about the plastic bag in the wind?
*Crowd shouts Firework.*
-Firefly!
Firefly.
That song.
Firework?
That would be my theme song cause I feel like a plastic bag in the wind.
*Tyler starts singing Firework*
Oh! Work by Rihanna.
That would be, that would be
*Tyler starts singing Work*
*Dylan and Khylin joins in with Tyler*
I don't know if they're good but I would go with the good vibrations.
*Tyler starts singing Good Vibrations*
-or like the Marky Mark one..
"You know what on second thought..." [Tyler] Is to touch people deeply, wait that's not right either
I wanna be inside of you guys, wait, that's .... Nah I'm off track
All I've ever wanted to do is inspire people positively, and inspire the world and make a difference in people's lives
And the amount of, uh, of people from all... from the years and thousands of fans that we have met throughout the years
Different parts of the world, everybody, there is always somebody who comes up to one of us
Ans says how much we've affected their lives and changed their lives for the better, and saved their lives
And whether it's one person in a group of a thousand people, or a group of a thousand people
It..it...every single person counts, and...and...I've uh, I don't know, I've always wanted just to change people's lives
And I really feel like this show has that power. I know counts of people that this show has bought together and I've learned
So much about myself and I have some of the best friends that I will have in my entire
Me and Dylan, this guy too... but Dylan O'Brien and I have this bond that I can't even go into words to try to explain
Or express and I just, I hope to God that everybody will find that and uh, this show has just, not only has it saved other people's lives
But it saved mine too. So this is just, like,  [Jeff] I'll, I'll add [Tyler] Add please, please [Jeff] It's an extraordinary feeling to
Because um, I, in high school always said